a lot of money that i wanted to make no  job would pay me with the exception of  investment banking management consulting  so you can make 5 10 20 million a year  as an investment banker but the path to  getting there the traditional way you  pretty much give 20 years and then you  start making that and i was like well i  want to give up my youth to have money  later that i won't have like the user  energy to spend that was kind of the  thought process every one of the big  advancements that i've had in my life  and i've like marked all of them like i  added a zero to my income per month each  time it was by giving up something that  everyone else told me was really good to  have something that was better i think  that's the hardest jump in life